I'm from Gay Times. All right. So, the
questions are going to be very
homosexual. Thank goodness. Right at my
warehouse. You know, we're ready. What I
love about Wicked, and I think what a
lot of people love about Wicked and this
story is that there are loads of queer
allegorories. Oz is so full of queerness
and celebration and beautiful
differences and so is Earth. Yeah.
Everyone is just so beautifully queer
and that roots all the way back to the
Elrank Bomb books where like literally
the most commonly used word in the books
is queer. As you said, Oz is a very
queer place. Every day in the Emerald
City is a pride parade. That's actually
great. But it's true. Even like the
chickens. I loved how rainbow and gay
was glorious. Glenda might be a little
in the closet. Our first day of
rehearsal, we both wore Balenciaga
hoodies. Mine was pink and said gay and
hers was black and said blendiaga. So
what you're saying is everyone in Oz is
I think so. I love it. Come on. Yeah.
We're about to talk about Wicked and
Wicked. There's a couple of things. The
what you just saw was there's a lot of
LGBT
Q+ influence in Wicked, at least from
the standpoint of the actors that are in
it. So, we're going to get into that a
little more, but have you two seen the
trailer for the new film, Wicked? Have
you seen it? I don't think I did. Okay.
So, I'm going to show it to you, but I
don't remember. And then there is at
least one thing that I thought was very
significant that I don't know how many
people would catch or even know to see
what the implications of that thing
were. Okay. So, I'm going to play it.
We'll see uh if you see eventually what
I saw and go from there.
[Music]
Ela Bthro, I know you're out here.
Just come in before the monkeys spot
you.
There's no going back.
This is between us and the wizard and I.
The wicked witch can't elude us forever.
Not with Prince Fiero and his squadron
hot on her trip.
The wonderful Wizard of Oz.
No one believed in you more than I did.
Alphaba,
they're coming for you.
I've heard it said that people come into
our lives for a reason.
I know I'm who I am today because I knew
you.
Think of what we could do together.
Like a cold morning as it passes a sign.
Like a sea drop of a sky
in our distant world.
Bring me the broom of the wicked witch
of the west.
For a while there, I thought you
changed.
I have changed.
It was time
for both of us to fly
because I knew you. You're the only
friend I ever had because I knew you and
I have so many friends. I have been
but only one that mattered.
I'm off to see the wizard.
[Music]
I don't know. Was it the white dress or
Okay. Uh I saw something on the letter
she opened. I don't know if that's the
letter she opened. She opened like a
piece of paper and said like, "I hope
you get what your heart desires." Okay.
Okay. Well, this is good. This will be
fun. Okay. So, we're going to we're
going to go on a a little bit of a
journey. The movie poster, as you can
see, says, "You will be changed for
good." Mhm. I think it's always
interesting when they direct that change
toward the people who are going to go
watch it, right? And of course in in the
trailer you you see with the music and
the song um they're saying that their
relationship has changed each other for
good right so that's the message of the
film you will be changed for good and I
want to challenge that notion I don't
think this is in any way going to change
people for good and there's a specific
reason for that. Okay. So, you saw the
uh cut of clips that were put together.
And that's not just, you know, it's not
just those actors that are putting that
out there. You can see from the
Sentimental Man podcast or Sentimental
Men podcast, a rainbow shirt in Target
won't turn your kids gay, but two
witches singing about their head
reeling, face flushing feelings for each
other absolutely will. Wow. No, that
could be sarcasm. I'll give them that.
That could be sarcasm, but I think that
podcast
is um well, let's just say I don't think
they're straight.
So, they're coming at it from
LGBT. Yeah.
Support that movement. Um and so even if
it's a joke, you know what they say
about jokes, right? It's always a little
bit of truth in it, right? So, is that
part of the plot from the musical? I
have no idea what's going out like. So,
this whole series is kind of
interesting. The Wicked
book. We're going to get to this in a
little bit, but this has nothing to do
with really the original movie, The
Wizard of Oz. And it's not it was not
written by the original author who wrote
that, LFrank Bomb. Okay. It was written
by another man who envisioned well what
this would this thing look like if it
had a backstory.
So this whole thing and like the
Broadway musical and all of that is like
a whole backstory that was created by an
author many years after the original
author. Okay. Made by a fan almost of
the show kind of. Yeah. This is from
Ariana Grande's Instagram. Oh, very
interesting post. She's a lesbian. He's
gay and they're 33 year marriage will
change your perception of love.
I mean, she wouldn't just say that if
that's not there's not some truth to it.
Wrap your head around that one, right?
Like why would they get married
when especially marriage is a sacred
thing and really it's a biblical
Christian thing. Yeah, it is. So, but
this is at least what she thinks about
the characters. So whether you're coming
at it as a as a viewer and coming in and
and looking at all that and saying,
"Well, I don't see it that way." Well,
she does. Mhm. And she was a huge fan of
the books, the series, the the whole
thing. I mean, she was watching the
Broadway musical as a little child. She
met the the the singers, and it's like
supposedly this was very
transformational in her life, and she's
read up on all this kind of stuff and
studied it. She knows a lot about this
series. Very interesting. Is this
something that is said in the musical or
in the movie or is this something just
something on her Instagram? Okay. From
Wicked Movie Updates on X. This was
posted last year.
Happy Pride Month from the Wicked Movie
Lesbian Flag Tulips. This is from the
set.
Oh, interesting. So, an aerial view and
they're just saying, you know,
essentially they planted tulips,
uh, I guess in the set. And I wanted to
look at that and say, oh, is that really
what it is? And there's the lesbian
flag. Yeah. And there's the set. It's
too similar for just being coincidence.
I mean, they weren't they weren't joking
or kidding. They were just like, "Yeah,
we're putting it out there. We're
putting the flag in." Mhm. Okay. So, you
could come at this and say, "Well,
they're just baiting people with all the
themes and all that kind of stuff, but I
think they're doing more than baiting
people." The majority of the cast
identifies with some alternative
lifestyle. At least the main like lead
actors. Okay. Mhm. I can't say for the
like the majority of the cast, like
everybody involved in the film, but the
majority of the lead actors are either
bisexual,
homosexual, you know, some trans,
something like that. Okay.
Now, the author Jeffrey Maguire, he says
that tension between the two that people
are seeing, at least as far as his book
is concerned,
it was intentional, that sexual tension.
So, here you go. This is the guy that
wrote it.
He says it was done on purpose. What I
think is wild is that kids watch this
movie. Like tons of kids are begging
their parents, I want to go see Wicked
and this is them and even Christian
children. Yeah. With Christian parents
who have no clue. Lots of people are
wanting to see this. Now, Jeffrey
Maguire, he is also one of those
individuals that he's a gay man. We have
a clip uh it's a short clip about 2
minutes on our on our YouTube channel.
We should put a link to this in the
description below where he flat out says
that he's Catholic, he's a gay man, you
know, so he is also probably putting
some of his own political, social, all
of that views into
this book that he's that he's made that
the Broadway musical was based on. Okay.
So that's Jeffrey Maguire.
Now, this is from an interview with Them
Us magazine, okay? Which is a LGBTQ plus
magazine, okay? And this is a quote from
this sitdown that they had with him. So,
Felipe, would you read this paragraph?
Some of these are questions that were on
Gregory Maguire's mind when he first sat
down to write Wicked, the life and time
of the wicked witch of the West. the
1995 adult novel on which the musical is
based. Maguire was inspired by evil
deeds, including a real life murder and
ongoing war. He had decided after
contemplating some other avenues to use
the world of Oz as a playground to plum
some very important questions. But to
make Oz tangible, he told them he needed
to give characters a multiplicity of
real life features including politics,
faith, and yes, sexuality.
Okay. So, in another video that we made
where we were talking about Ariana
Grande and how she proclaimed to be a
witch. Think in that one I might have
mentioned that if you go to the fandom
for the wicked um movies and look up his
book he says this was written his book
right here the wicked the life and times
of the wicked witch of the west was
written as a um social no it was written
as a moral and ethical commentary on the
nature of good and evil.
Okay. All right. So, here's the
follow-up paragraph to that. Denise,
could you read this? That was
intentional, and it was modest and
restrained and refined in such a way
that one could imagine that one of those
two young women had felt more than the
other and had not wanted to say it. Or
perhaps because a novelist can't write
every scene. Perhaps when the lights
were out and the novelist was out having
a smoke in the back alley, the girls had
sex in the bed on the way to the Emerald
City. I wanted to propose this
possibility, but I did not want to make
a declarative statement about. So he
didn't write it in. Mhm. But he says,
"This is how I imagine all of this
playing out as part of his, you know,
vision for the story." So he's like, you
know, I didn't write it in there, but
I'm basically seeing them as like, you
know, when I'm on a a coffee break or a
smoke break that they're having sex
as as part of the story line because I
can't write every scene in. Yeah. Well,
because he this this is the essence of
Hollywood that a lot of it is subliminal
messaging. So, it seems like very much
wicked is subliminal messaging with the
LGBTQ agenda and it's written in Yeah.
It's just subliminal and he's suggesting
it by the way that he's writing the
story. Yeah. Okay. All right. So, Steven
Schwarz when this thing was made into a
musical, Steven Schwarz was the composer
for the Wicked musical. Okay. He's the
guy that that handled all the music and
he did an interview with Ecumenica which
is a journal for theater and performance
and here are a couple of points from the
article. If you wouldn't mind reading
that one. I have two um to see what he
says about this. So this is the person
that's interviewing him. They're making
the first statement. Let's see. How
about a question about Wicked
specifically to move up more to the
present? In an article on Wicked,
Chicago Tribune critics Chris Jones
claims that a Fordham University student
wrote a 25page thesis on a
Judeo-Christian theme in the show. And
also, I noticed that Ben Bradley's
review that he called it a sermon of a
musical. You could take that several
ways, but what I was wondering was did
you and your collaborator Winnie
Holesman foresee the connections between
wicked and religion that have been made?
Okay, so he's been interviewed about
this and they're asking him was there
intentional religious and
um connections. So here's his response.
Denique. Well, I think we clearly were
dealing with the ethical issues and
moral issues and obviously religion
comes into play when one is dealing with
that. I think that is part of the
content of the show. I don't know that I
would agree with calling it a sermon
because I think it's somewhat
even-handed or fairly evenhanded in the
approach it takes. I think the whole
point of a sermon is really not to be
evenhanded but to take a very strong
point of view. But writers have points
of view and those are going to show up
in their work. I know Mr. Brantley
didn't mean that in a comp complimentary
fashion when he wrote that, but frankly
I think that most things that people
write are sermons of one sort or another
if they have any moral content
whatsoever.
Very interesting. Definitely. So as a
composer, he's like, well, I wouldn't
call it a sermon, but most things that
people write are sermons. Yeah. Mhm. And
the points of view of the writers are
going to show up in their work. Mhm. So
he's affirming this now. Um
and I think you know when you see people
being interviewed about this film that
they they all are kind of confirming
that there is a message being
communicated through the the media or
medium that they're choosing. So, let's
talk a little bit more about Steven
Schwarz. Schwarz uh does not appear to
be married, at least not any longer. He
has children, but he currently has a
longtime partner.
This is this Steven Schwarz is still the
the composer, right? Composer. Okay.
Okay. His longtime partner is Michael
McCroy Rose, and that is on their
website. So So he is also a gay man.
That's a lot of them.
So, this is from Forbes magazine. It's
wicked composer Steven Schwarz reveals
origination of hit song for good is
concert celebrating musical set to air.
What did he say was the inspiration
um for that for the hit song for good?
Yeah. And this all the songs that you
said you know was that for the movie all
the songs that are in the musical I
think are essentially in the movie. all
or at least most of them. Okay. So, what
did he say was the inspiration? Would
you mind reading this? He's quick to
add, I want to give the bookw writer of
Wicked, Winnie Holtzman, some credit
because she actually came up with the
title when we were first talking about
the final song for Alphaba and Glenda.
And I was brainstorming with her and at
one point she just said in the
conversation, "Well, you know, they have
had such an impact on one another.
really they have changed each other for
good. And I said, I'm hanging up now
because that's one of the best titles
for a song I can imagine. Thank you for
giving me the title. Now I'm going to
write it. So they got the title first
and then he wrote it. And and he makes
this this this statement or at least
from from when he's getting well they
changed each other for good. That's
actually a double meaning. Okay. And I
know this because there was another
clip. I didn't put it in here, but from
Steven Schwarz where he says it has a
double meaning. So the for good is
they've changed each other for good.
Like in other words, to be good or help
sharpen their character to better one
another. Better one another for good.
But also for good as in permanently like
this thing cannot be undone. It's it's
unalterable now. Whatever is done is
done for good. And then the context is
really interesting of the story that if
they if this is just a subliminal
messaging of the LGBTQ and the they're
both just lesbians and they're both just
like in love with each other secretly,
then they're like changed into that
forever. Can't go back. Yeah. So my
question is, well, what's
what's good? Mhm. God God is good. How
how do you know what is what is good?
Mhm. We're going to get to how the Bible
defines what is good, but I just want to
put that question in your mind. What is
good? How do we know what's good? How
what defines things as being good?
Because by this, you know, they're
saying, "Well, they've changed each
other each other for good." Well, then
anybody could say anything is good, but
that doesn't make it good. Right. Right.
Okay. Now, there's another element that
you'll see creeping up into here. So,
I'm going to show you a clip that they
did an interview with the variety. It's
not the whole thing, but just a portion
of the clip. I think this is very
fascinating the way they phrased this
part of the conversation. Who did Ariana
see the original stage show of Wicked
with?
This one is boring
apparently. Yeah. Come on. I remember
being so swept off my feet by just the
story and the comedy really stayed with
me when I was little. I don't think at
that point I had seen anything. I mean,
I was 10, but I don't think I'd seen
anything that moved me that way. Did you
meet Kristen that day? Yeah, I did. She
gave me body gel. She says it's bath
salts, but it was it was body gel. It
had glitter in. I think it had actual
witchcraft magic in it. I really do.
There's no way you get to this without
that witchcraft. I think it there's a
combination of real magic,
manifestation, and hard work that needs
to happen for things like this to
happen. Don't you think? I think so.
I'm just thinking of the the
manifestation because it's interesting
that she groups it all together. She's
like real magic, manifestation, and hard
work. I I mean, I agree. I'm sure they
work really hard, you know. I'm sure
they do. But we understand manifestation
as being a new age concept. Mhm. You
know, we did a whole show on this of of
this this guy who basically left
Christianity and how did he get into
manifestation, which is um another term
for it is um the law of attraction. The
law of attraction. Yeah. So, he said the
reason he got into it was because of
thinking and growing yourself rich and
the book the secret. Yeah, you know,
it's this whole idea of like I I want it
and so I'm going to meditate on it and
it's going to appear in my life. As in
you are the one in control making that
thing happen. Yes. Yes. So very
interesting. Uh just kind of a tangent
but from history. Where does the law of
attraction come from? I don't know. Good
question. You don't know? No, I don't
think. Oh, fascinating. So, it's
credited as being um first written about
from a lady named Helena Blavatski. Oh,
didn't know that. Really? Yes. Major.
So, major occultist. Blavsky wrote about
this in the 1800s now in some research
I'm doing on for a long-term project. I
mean, I've been looking at this for like
probably close to 10 years now. um which
have not published this yet.
But Blavatzki the year that she's
credited with writing that and using
that term, she's actually not the first
person in literature I found to use
that. So the first time it actually
appears in literature is 10 years prior
to the claim that Bllovsky published it
and it was written down by a man named
Andrew Jackson Davis. Was he also an
occultist? You could say that. Yes,
because he was somebody who he kind of
drew inspiration from two sources of
people. One was the Shakers and another
one was a man by the name of Emanuel
Swedenborg.
And Andrew Jackson Davis was this very
strange story. He basically was not he
didn't have a high school education,
but he
you know had predicted the speed of
light.
like 80 years before it was calculated.
He predicted like automobiles and he um
claimed to have communicated with past
individuals from history. He was the one
very fascinating tidbit from history.
Andrew Jackson Davis was the one who had
a journal. Um he was you could say
essentially communicating with the other
side. in his journal on March 31, 1848,
there was an entry that said, um,
"Brother, the good work has begun."
Okay, it's like, well, that's kind of
random. What kind of work does that have
to do with that? The good the good work
has begun.
That was the same date. And then that
night in the same part of the country
that the Fox sisters first heard the
rapping and started communicating with
Mr. Splitfoot. Well, you have to maybe
give a little one sentence brief
description who the Fox sisters are for
those who don't spiritualist
were Yeah. a group of sisters who um
they essentially toured the US and parts
of Europe claiming to communicate with
the dead. Yep. And that was first done
in their home in New York. Right. In New
York. And today at their home, you can
find a plaque that says
um you know there is no death, there are
no dead. And it was that plaque was put
there by the spiritualists of the world.
They date it, you know, talk about their
philosophy. But anyway, that's like a
whole another tangent. It's a whole
another topic. I'm hoping to produce a
documentary on that whole thing at some
point in the future because there's a
ton of information about spiritualism
and all these people that are connected
and scientists and historical figures
and what they believed, what they were
trying to accomplish, all of that. So
anyway, total tangent, right?
Getting back to this
very interesting choice of words. Like
why would you even say that? And not
only that, she has claimed that she's a
a witch herself. The wicked the wicked
is witch. The wicked is witch. So I
would imagine she knows a thing or two
about what she's talking about. She uses
tarot cards on set of wicked. But but
also if you think about it, the law of
attraction, right, and how deeply it is
actually connected to oultism and
spiritualism. Lavatzka whom you
mentioned, she's an open worshipper of
Lucifer, of Satan. Um, but the Bible
clearly speaks against witchcraft as
well, which should be a reason in the
first place for Christians not to watch
this. But exactly, it it so witchcraft
is from Satan. Um, the law of attraction
or manifestation or manifesting is from
Satan. Yeah. And so it's like she just
puts everything together. If it's coming
from Bllovsky, it's not coming from God.
I mean, she has statements like in the
secret doctrine. I think it's on page 79
where she says um she says something
like uh she's talking about Lucifer the
lightbearer and um how he had to be
sacrificed to the new the new dogma
because he is older and higher than
Jehovah.
I mean that's just that's what she said.
So if she's talking and promoting
something like the law of attraction,
you can I can guarantee you it's not
coming from God
[Music]
and he for you Israel
I will make him a pillar in the temple
of my God and he shall go out no more. I
will ride on him in the name of my God.
Be strong in the Lord and in the power
shall strength. He shall mount things
like he shall run and not
but by every word that proceeds from the
mouth of God.
It's interesting that you mentioned
these things about what the Bible says
to say about witchcraft, right? We know
from Deuteronomy 18 10-12 says, "There
shall not be found among you anyone who
makes a son or daughter pass through the
fire or one who practices witchcraft or
a soothsayer or one who interprets omens
or a sorcerer or one who conjures spells
or a medium or a spiritist or one who
calls up the dead. For all who do these
things are an abomination to the Lord
and because of these abominations, the
Lord your God drives them out from
before you." If you go on to read that
passage, it says, you know, the Lord has
not given these things to you, something
like that. I'm I'm kind of paraphrasing,
but it's not just something that was in
the Old Testament. No, that it's like,
okay, well, that was for Christians then
or Israelites then. It it doesn't apply
to Christianity today. No, no, no.
Entirely false. The Bible says in
Revelation 2:18, Felipe, "But the
cowardly, unbelieving, abominable,
murderers, sexually immoral, sorcerers,
idoltors,
and all liars shall have their part in
the lake which burns with fire and
brimstone, which is the second death."
So clearly, Old Testament, New
Testament, both agree. Sorcerers,
witchcraft, soothsayers, that's right.
all of that,
those people, God finds that abomination
and they are not going to be found in
the kingdom of God. That's not to say
people who used to do that can't come
out of that and be converted.
Absolutely. They're not beyond the reach
of God, right? But if they continue to
persist in those activities, then God
will say, "There's no place for you in
my kingdom because I have strictly
forbidden this." It's
impersonating the voice of God to God's
people if you think about it because God
communicates through prophets by the
power of the Holy Spirit and gives
messages. Well, this is like Satan's
counterfeit for that. So, you can
understand where God would say this is
strictly forbidden. I cannot have this
because it's too confusing for people.
It would lead them astray. Yep. So, we
talked about how do we know what's good
and what's not good? You need to have a
compass of morality. You do. You can't
just because we live in a time and place
um in postmodernism where there's this
idea of everybody has their own sense of
morality of of what is right and what is
wrong. That just destroys human hum
humanity. Mhm. Because if you think that
it is right to practice witchcraft or um
to to commit the most abominable crimes,
then you can say, "Oh, I can just do
that and there is no law against me."
Right? When But when we have a compass
like the Bible, we know this is what is
right and this is what is best for
humanity and we're all on the same page.
Not just because we're all on the same
page, but we're doing all the wicked
stuff. We're all on the same page.
actually genuinely loving God and loving
each other without a a
straight definition of morality on
what's good and evil. It's up to each
person to decide what's good. So, who am
I to tell you you shouldn't steal
because that's not good, right? And you
go on and say, "Oh, it's good. I'm doing
it for a reason. I think the reason is
good." Yeah. Right. Well, that's why we
need the Bible. Like you were saying,
the Bible says in Romans 13:10-12
that
none of us are actually good. That's
right. There's none good. None who does
good. No, not one. Like we're all in
this condition where none of us apart in
our in our own selves, we will tend
towards sin. And so we need God to to
essentially do good. Now people can do
nice things. They can do good things.
But the Bible also indicates that all of
that if anyone does anything good, it
comes from God. Whether you are
believing in God or not, he's saying I
am the one that is able to help people
do those things whether they realize
who's working in their life or not.
But essentially there's there's there's
nobody that is good. this idea that
they're putting out in this film that
they've been changed for good because
they have this relationship. We also see
that there's this mixing of light and
darkness.
Is that what they portray? Like like
Cynthia Aria's character is like the bat
witch and Ariana Grand characters like
the good witch. I see the yin-yang
system. She, you know, Al Faba is
getting frustrated because she believes
that what she is doing is good. But it's
it's quite fascinating. You saw in the
trailer, this is the wizard is lying to
us. Alphaba is the green. The green
witch. Yeah.
Why is that bad,
right? If there is no standard for
morality, and how do you define
morality? How do you know that? Why? Why
is lying a problem? Mhm. Right. So, she
gets frustrated because she believes
everything she's trying to do is good
and it's not appreciated. Mhm. And so,
then she essentially makes a vow that
she's not going to do good anymore.
Okay. And all of her tactics are not
going to be good moving forward.
Well, then how can you call that good?
because she's consider how can somebody
like that change somebody else right to
be good. I mean, there's all kinds of
like questions that swirl. Yeah. When
you're talking about, well, what's good
and what's not good and how they change
and what they decide to do and not not
do and the sides that they take, you
know, being pitted against each other
like that with this mixing of light and
darkness. Would you read 1 John 5:7?
Just uh Felipe, this is what the Bible
says about
light and darkness.
1 John 1:5-7 says, "This is the message
which we have heard from him and
declared to you that God is light and in
him is no darkness at all. If we say
that we have fellowship with him and
walk in darkness, we lie and do not
practice the truth. But if we walk in
the light as he is in the light, we have
fellowship with one another. And the
blood of Jesus Christ, his son, cleanses
us from all sin
in order for us to have light or be in
the light. We have to walk in the light
as he is in the light. That's very
clear. Mhm. There there's no two ways
about this. God is light. In him is no
darkness at all. Amen. There's no mixing
of these two. That's right. which is
especially important with the next point
I'm going to share. H.
So, this is the fandom page for the
Wicked movie and it's talking about this
song for good, right? There's a quote I
found on this page
and it says, "This song is performed
towards the end of the musical." Okay,
this this poor good, you know, that that
has the double meaning, right? In it,
the two are singing farewell to one
another. So they the farewell is we've
changed each other for good and
permanently.
Just prior to the song, Alaba gives
Glenda the grimmory and tells her that
it is up to her to continue Alaba's
cause. What's the grimmory? Oh, that's a
fascinating question, isn't it? So, this
is the grimmorary. Okay, this was in the
trailer. Did you see this? I noticed
something. I I can't I still can't. You
saw it in the trailer.
In the lyrics to the song for this, it
um talks about what good is this
chanting. You heard chanting in the
trailer. Do you remember? She said these
words that you probably didn't
understand. Like what language is that?
That's chanting. As soon as I saw that
and heard that, I was like, "Oh boy."
It's like basically make the hair on the
back of your neck stand up. She's
casting a spell. Mhm. In the trailer, in
the movie. Come on, guys. Now, what are
the what are the words? The the words
are made up from different languages. I
don't remember what it meant. Uh it had
something to do with the story line, but
the point is she's casting a spell and
they're passing the baton from one
person to the next is she's giving her
the grimmory. Okay. What is the
grimmory? I want to point out real quick
because I know where you're going with
this. Yes. And I want to point out that
this looks like a bunch of sun rays. It
does look like a bunch of sun rays. And
you notice in here there's a bunch of
symbols. Yes. Okay. You can see them in
in various parts of the screenshot.
Okay. What's a grim on the Wicked
fandom? Again, this is their their
stuff. Like I didn't make this up. The
grimmorary known on earth as the lesser
key of Solomon is a magical spell book
or grimoire of magnificent power which
Alaba finds in the attic of Kiamo co and
was later given to her by Serma. Alfaba
can only read parts of it as the book
originates from the other world which is
earth. The book also created Yakal to be
a guardian to the book and a witness to
the tragic life of Alaba.
Do you know what the lesser key of
Solomon is? No. Okay. Well, let's find
out. I I recognize Solomon. I know about
the Lesser Key of Solomon from working
here many years. Scotty has talked about
this many times.
The Lesser Key of Solomon is a grimoire
or a text of magical incantations. In
fact, this is one of the most
known or or comprehensive books on
magic. The Lesser Key of Solomon. The
Lesser Key of Solomon. Like, it's an
actual thing. It's an actual thing. Oh,
so it's a text of magical incantations
and spells that are said to have been
written by King Solomon. Actually,
nobody believes that, but that's what
it's called. Even people that practice
all this stuff, they know it's not
written by Solomon, who is a legendary
figure in Jewish, Islamic, and Christian
traditions, right? The text is divided
into five books. And the second book
known as the Ar Godia is one that is
famous for its description of the 72
demons and their corresponding sigils.
Interesting. So yeah, there are 72
beings that are listed in this book as
demons
that people claim to have communicated
with and named. And there is a symbol
for each one of them to invoke that
specific demon for a specific reason,
for a specific thing. And this is all in
a familyfriendly movie. I mean, it is.
It goes on. says according to the text
the 72 demons were summoned by King
Solomon and bound to his will so that he
could use their powers for various
purposes. Now that's fascinating and
Solomon would have known about power
both ways if you read the Bible. He
would have known about the power of God
and he would have known that that is
more powerful. So why resort to this?
But we also know that Solomon did dabble
in things of the occult.
Each demonic spirit is associated with a
specific sigil, a symbol, or a seal
representing the demon's name and power.
It goes on to say, "The sigils are said
to be powerful tools for summoning and
commanding the demons. They still should
only be used by experienced
practitioners of magic as they can be
dangerous if misused.
In fact, the text warns that the demon
should not be summoned for idle
curiosity or frivolous reasons as they
can be unpredictable and even harmful.
Okay. H
lesser key of Solomon. What's in it?
There are many contributors to this
through since probably like the 14th
century or so. One of the later
contributors to this was Samuel Lidell
McGregor Mathers. He was one of the
last. In fact, he he worked with another
individual. Um, but he compiled a lot of
the information, but it was um published
I'll tell you who it was published by in
a second, but this is the very first
paragraph of the lesser key of Solomon.
Okay, Denique, would you read this? It
is lofty amusing to the student of
magical literature who is not quite a
fool and rare is such a combination to
note the criticism directed by the
Philistine against the citadel of his
science. Truly since our childhood has
ingrained into us not only literal
belief in the Bible but also substantial
belief in elf Leila wila and only
adolescence can cure us. We are only too
liable in the Russian energy of dawning
manhood to overturn roughly and rashly
both these classics to regard them both
on the same level as interesting
documents from the standpoint of
folklore and anthropology and as nothing
more. So they're saying the Bible and
that other book which I think is Arabian
Knights, right? They're saying those are
on the same level as interesting
documents from the standpoint of
folklore and anthropology and as nothing
more. And this is in the lesser key of
Solomon. Less lesser key of Solomon.
Okay. Bible. Not really. That's just
fall. Even though the Bible is the one
Even though the Bible is the one that
confirms that Solomon existed. Yeah, I
know. Good point. Right. Put it all in
perspective.
This is the book that Alaba has that
she's casting a spell from to release
Prince Fier, I think. and the book that
she's also handing off to Glenda to
continue to promote her cause. So, this
book is central to their relationship
and cause. Now, you're I don't know if
you have this on here, but you were
showing me like a seal of Baal that was
somehow connected to the the lesser key
of Solomon, right? Yes. Baal is the
first demon. Okay. There's first name
sigil number one. Mhm. It reminded me of
another symbol. I there's no way I could
conclusively say that those two things
are related. But when I saw it, I was
like, "Wow, that actually looks like the
Vatican
emblem." Mhm.
I just wanted to point it out because
the Bale was a a god of sun worship.
Yes. Yes. And then her grim had all of
the rays coming out of it and stuff.
Now, there are some people that
correlate Baal the demon with Baal the
god in the Bible, but there are some
that do not. They are not necessarily
the same thing according according to
occult people. Okay, I see. Now, it
might be, it might not. I don't know. I
think you could probably dig and
determine that whether it is or not.
Either way, Baal was known for like they
would sacrifice their children to Baal.
And so if in the Bible Yeah. Yeah. And
in history too. So if that is the case,
let's just say it is the case that this
Bale is the same as in the book, which
this book is used in the movie. Yeah.
That's very disturbing. It is very
disturbing and and odd that they have
basically the same name. Like there's a
demon named Baal and then there's this
character in the Bible that has all
these abominable activities associated,
right? A false god in the Bible. Yeah. A
false god. Uh the Bible does say I think
it's Paul that says, you know, the um
the gods that they worshiped or the gods
that they sacrificed to they sacrificed
to demons. Mhm. You know, so it's like,
well,
yeah. you know. Anyway, so Mathers was
the last person who was compiling
information from this book, but it was
published by
Alistister Crowley. This the Lakia
Solomon. Yes. In 1904. Wait, he he
published he published the book. He was
the editor and published the book. So
Alistister Crowley, Satanist, magician.
Yes. and like vile vile vow says right
there the wickedest man in the world and
that was the press of the day.
Fascinating term though that they called
him the wickedest
man. Yep. In the world. Yeah. He he
wrote a book called um the book of the
law. Mhm. Has all kinds of
anti-Christian
things in it. I think I think the book
of the law is the one where we have the
quote where he says do as thou wilt as
the whole of the law. But that's
interesting going back to wicked where
they take away the the moral compass and
it's like there is no moral compass
anywhere. You do whatever you want to do
and what you think is good is good. What
you think is evil is evil. That really
goes back to what Alistister Crowley is
saying. Do what thou wilt should be the
whole of the law. Yeah. He wrote another
book. I'm trying to remember what it's
called. was like blood sex and magic or
something like that. Um yeah, he he
wrote many books largely in the realm of
the occult and he was not known to be
somebody you would want as a next door
neighbor. We'll just put it that way.
Yeah. You probably won't make it out
alive. Yeah. So he Yeah. He was a very
evil evil man. M
so another fascinating um point I
discovered when when looking this up
specifically when it came to sigils
and there was a book called the book of
lies the disinformation guide to magic
and the occult and it has a lot of
contributors so people that are they're
pulling from as um sources of authority
to clear up people's misunderstandings
about what magic is and what what it's
not. You can see the list of people that
are on here. Grant Morrison,
Alistister Crowley. Grant Morrison is a
comic book author. Yeah. Anton Ley, he
founded the Church of Satan in the US.
So these are these are some heavy
hitters, right? In the occult. Well, in
Grant Morrison's portion, he talks about
sigils. Mhm. Okay, his his section is
called like pop magic or whatever. Um,
so this is what he says. In the pop
magic style, the sigil is the first and
one of the most effective of all weapons
in the arsenal of any modern magician.
The sigil technique was reconceptualized
and modernized by Austin Osman Spar in
the early 20th century and popularized
by chaos magicians in the temple of
psychic youth in the 1980s.
A sigil is a magically charged symbol
like this one. Then he gives an example
which that is probably one from the
lesser key of Solomon. He goes on to say
that the sigil takes a magical desire or
intent. Let's say it's my desire to be a
great actor. You can and of course put
any desire you want in there. What is
this starting to sound like? Do with
that will chubby to hold the law. What
else? The law of attraction, right?
Okay. Yes. Yeah. and folds it down,
creating a highly charged symbol. The
desire is then forgotten. Only the
symbol remains, and you can then be
charged to full potency when the
magician chooses. Forgetting the desire
in its verbal form can be difficult, he
says, if started too ambitiously.
There's no point charging a symbol to
win the lottery if you don't buy a
ticket. So, they're saying, "Yeah, you
need the sigil, but you also need to act
on it," which is the same thing they
teach in the law of attraction. Mhm.
Mhm. Right. Yeah. That's that's pretty
much manifesting right there. So, start
with stuff that's not too emotionally
involving. He says, "I sigilized to meet
people I'm interested in or for
particular qualities I'll need in a
given situation. I've also used sigils
for healing."
Fascinating. For locating lost objects
and for mass global change. What do all
those things have in common? What would
you say? Cue the Jeopardy music, right?
Mhm. Those are things I'd pray about.
Oh, right. Lose your keys, can't find
them. Couple hours, you pray about it.
Right. That's a good point. Somebody
that needs to be healed, you pray about
it. Global change, you pray about it.
Right. I don't have any power. God has
power. That's true. Yeah. So, he says,
"I've been using them for 20 years and
they always
work." This is Grant Morrison. Now, now,
now Keith, when you lose your keys
and let's say you haven't prayed about
it, are you just going to sit there and
like, uh, I'm going to find my keys like
that? No. You have to search and search
and search and and even when you pray,
doesn't mean God doesn't have the power.
But sometimes he allows you to go
through that moment. Like personally,
sometimes it's really irritating when I
find lose my keys. And that's a moment
of reflection of like thank you Lord for
using this opportunity to teach me
character growth. Right? There's reasons
why God doesn't always allow to uh
answer the prayer immediately. And then
in in this case it's like there's
another force at play clearly that will
just like we'll help you find your keys.
here's your keys. You know, immediate
instant gratification which God is the
opposite of that because he wants to you
to see to search your heart to show your
character even in the little things like
not finding your keys. Yeah. So he goes
on and I know this is like a long
section but I think the context is
important. Mhm. So the last thing he
says is for me the period between
launching the signal the sigil and its
manifestation as a realworld event is
usually 3 days 3 weeks or three months
depending on the variables involved. So
if he wants to meet somebody 3 days 3
weeks three months and then he repeats
he says I repeat sigils always work. M
so this is like to debunk what people
think about magic. He's talking about
symbols and he's like this is the real
deal. I use this all the time. This is
how they work. It's accurate and they
always work. Yeah. And this is how part
of the occult operates.
I want to end on something that the
Bible says. It comes from Ephesians
chapter 5 8-14. So, I'm going to ask um
you two to read this in closing. For you
were once darkness, but now you are
light in the Lord. Walk as children of
light.
For the fruit of the spirit is in all
goodness, righteousness, and truth,
finding out what is acceptable to the
Lord, and have no fellowship with the
unfruitful works of darkness, but rather
expose them. For it is shameful even to
speak of those things which are done by
them in secret. But all things that are
exposed are made manifest by the light.
For whatever makes manifest is light.
Therefore he says, "Awake you who sleep,
arise from the dead, and Christ will
give you light." Paul wrote this to a
church that was steeped into the occult
once upon a time. The Ephesians were the
ones that had the magic books that were
burned. They were used to seeing an this
kind of activity. They had come out of
that and his advice to them is don't
have anything to do with that anymore.
In fact, expose that kind of stuff. It's
not from God. You need to walk in the
light. Amen. And not with this other
stuff. So, as Christians, we see this.
This is in a film that is marketed to
families.
We should have nothing to do with this.
That's right. Because it's only
promoting occult ideals, occult
philosophies, and things that are not
going to put us on the path to heaven.
So, be careful what you watch. You don't
always know what's going into the
thought process behind it or what
they're putting into it or why. And it
looks like it's just a story about
friendship, but it's a whole lot more
you're g than that is what you're
getting. If you like this video, like,
subscribe, and hit the notification bell
so you know when we launch new videos.
And drop a comment below, and we'll try
to get back to you if we can. What?
Say that again. No. No. I don't know
what to say.
[Music]